when we first heard the the floor crack  and boom  i did not expect that the next day we  would be closed or  in or even more for eight months through  the first day was like  what's gonna happen you know what are we  gonna do but then we  me and my dad quickly changed it into a  positive and said  okay let's make the bar bigger let's get  all these things that we need to  do fix and yeah it turned out better  than what we expected yeah we're happy  that we're back  up and running at 100 super happy that  everyone is so  you know i opened the door and  everyone's like yes finally you guys are  open  you know or people calling like when are  you going to open so it's a  it's a great feeling it's great i love  people who this is their first time come  in  and i see the see how it is at the bar  especially our  our main are what we're really proud of  is how we the bar turned out  so we love that people who never came  here before heard about it come in and  are  seeing it newly improved